veronica y louis están en grupos
diferentes de física en la escuela santa
rita los exámenes que realiza la maestra
de lewis siempre tienen 30 preguntas
mientras que el maestro de veronica
realiza exámenes con mayor frecuencia
con solo 24 preguntas además la maestra
de louis les asigna tres proyectos por
año aún cuando los dos grupos tendrán un
número diferente de exámenes sus
maestros les han dicho que ambos grupos
responderán el mismo número total de
preguntas de examen en el transcurso del
año cuál es el número mínimo de
preguntas que podría tener que responder
cada grupo en un año pensemos que está
sucediendo aquí pensemos en la maestra
de louis que realiza 30 preguntas por
examen después del primer examen habrá
presentado 30 preguntas aquí tenemos el
0 después del segundo examen habrá
presentado 60 preguntas después del
tercer examen habrá presentado 90
después del cuarto examen habrá
presentado 120 después de su quinto
examen si existiera un quinto examen
habrá presentado un total de 150
preguntas y así podremos seguir y seguir
con todos los múltiplos de 30 así que
tal vez esta sea una pista de lo que
estamos buscando estamos buscando los
múltiplos de estos números y queremos el
mínimo de esos múltiplos bien esta es la
situación con la maestra de louis cuál
es la situación con el maestro de
veronica bueno el maestro de veronica
después del primer examen habrá
presentado 24 preguntas después del
segundo examen habrá presentado 48
preguntas después del tercer examen
habrá presentado 72 después del cuarto
examen solo estamos tomando 2 múltiplos
de 24 después del cuarto examen habrá
presentado 96 preguntas y después del
quinto examen habrá presentado 120
preguntas
si existieran un sexto examen habrá
presentado 144 preguntas y podríamos
seguir de ser necesario pero leamos de
nuevo la pregunta cuál es el número
mínimo de preguntas que podría tener que
responder cada grupo en un año bueno el
número mínimo es el punto en el que
ambos tienen la misma cantidad de
preguntas de examen a pesar del hecho de
que los exámenes tienen un número
diferente de preguntas y podemos ver que
el punto en el que ambos tienen el mismo
número es 120 ambos grupos reciben 120
preguntas a pesar de que la maestra de
louis presenta 30 preguntas cada vez ya
pesar de que el profesor de veronica
presenta 24 preguntas en cada examen
entonces la respuesta es 120 observa
tenemos un número diferente de exámenes
louis va a realizar
234 exámenes mientras que verónica va a
realizar 1 2 3 4 5 exámenes pero ambos
van a responder
un total de 120 preguntas ahora si
pensamos esto en notación matemática o
en la anotación del mínimo común
múltiplo que hemos visto antes realmente
nos están preguntando cuál es el mínimo
común múltiplo de 30 y 24 y ese mínimo
común múltiplo es 120 ahora además de
observar los múltiplos de esta forma
existen otras formas distintas para
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo
podemos encontrarlo mediante la
factorización en primos así que vamos a
hacerlo 30 es dos veces 15 que a su vez
es 3 veces 5 así que podemos decir que
30 am es igual a 2 por 3 por 5 mientras
que 24 es igual a 2 veces 12
12 a su vez es dos veces 66 es dos veces
tres y entonces 24 es igual a 2 por 2
por 2 por 3 así que otra forma de
obtener el mínimo común múltiplo si no
hemos desarrollado este ejercicio por
acá arriba es decir el número que tiene
que ser divisible tanto por 30 como por
24 como debe de ser divisible por 30 va
a tener que tener dos por tres por cinco
en su factor y zación en números primos
esto es básicamente 30 esto lo hace
divisible entre 30 y decir como debe de
ser divisible entre 24 su factorización
en números primos debe de multiplicar 3
12 y 13 pero ya tenemos un 3 y ya
tenemos un 2 así que necesitamos agregar
2 2 es más así que
por dos así que todo esto lo hace es
divisible por 24 básicamente toda esta
es la factorización en números primos
del mínimo común múltiplo de 30 y 24 si
quitamos cualquiera de estos números ya
no será divisible entre 24 o entre 30 si
quitamos un 2 o un 3 ya no será
divisible entre 24 si quitamos un 3 o un
5 ya no será divisible entre 30 y si
multiplicamos todos estos números
tendremos que 2 por 2 por 2 es 8 8 por 3
24 24 por 5 120 bien hagamos un problema
más
elena compro un paquete de 21 carpetas
vamos a encerrarlo y un paquete de 30
lápices 30 lápices ella quiere usar
todos los lápices y las carpetas para
armar juegos idénticos de material de
oficina para sus compañeros de clase
cuál es el número máximo de juegos
idénticos que elena puede formar con
todo este material
y que esta vez nos pidan el número
máximo es una pista de que probablemente
se trate del máximo común divisor y
también de dividir estos paquetes vamos
a tener que dividir a ambos paquetes en
el número máximo de conjuntos idénticos
así que hay un par de formas distintas
de abordar este problema busquemos el
máximo común divisor de estos dos
números o podemos decir el máximo factor
común el máximo común divisor de 21 y 30
cuál es el número más grande que los
divide a ambos bueno podemos tomar la
factorización en primos o podemos
enlistar todos sus factores y ver cuál
es el máximo factor común así que usemos
el método de factorizar en primos 21 es
lo mismo que 3 por 7 y ambos son números
primos 30 es lo mismo que 2 por 15 y de
hecho lo acabamos de hacer 15 a su vez
3 x 5
entonces cuál es el número más grande de
números primos que son comunes en ambas
factorización es bueno solo tenemos al 3
por aquí no tenemos 3 por algo más así
que esto será igual a 3 lo que nos dice
esto es que podemos dividir
estos números entre 3 y esto nos dará el
mayor número de conjuntos idénticos
espero que quede claro que estamos
haciendo la respuesta a la pregunta es 3
pero vamos a visualizar este problema
dibujemos 21 carpetas digamos que las 21
carpetas son estas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 y 21
y estos serán los 30 lápices uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez déjame copiar y pegar esto se está
volviendo tedioso copiamos y pegamos
tenemos 20 y si pegamos de nuevo tenemos
30 entonces acabamos de encontrar que 3
es el número más grande que divide
equitativamente ambos conjuntos es decir
puedo dividir ambos conjuntos en grupos
de 3 podemos dividir las carpetas en
tres grupos de 7 mientras que para los
lápices tenemos tres grupos de 10
entonces si vienen tres personas a este
salón de clases podemos darles a cada
uno de ellos siete carpetas y diez
lápices
este es el número más grande de
conjuntos idénticos que elena puede
hacer tenemos tres conjuntos y cada uno
de ellos tiene siete carpetas y diez
lápices básicamente estamos pensando
cuál es el número más grande que puede
dividir ambos conjuntos equitativamente